- I mentioned though that you're also in
it's called the order of Canada.
- Yes.
And you were promoted.
One I see the pen but what is this?
What does this mean?
What is this promotion?
You're a companion.
Is that what you are?
- Now a companion to the order of Canada.
Being named to the order of Canada
honestly is a great honor.
- Okay.
- You know when you get
named to the order of Canada
it's the highest civilian honor
you you can achieve in Canada
which is a truly a great honor.
But there are three categories
to the order of Canada.
When you, when you,
when you be, when, when,
when you become a
member, you are a member,
but then you can be promoted to officer
of the Order of Canada.
- Okay.
And then companion to the order of Canada
is the highest order
and there are only restricted number
of companions to the order of Canada.
- Oh.
- So I had, I was fortunate
enough to have friends.
My good friend Marty Short.
- Yep.
- Was also became a member
of the order of Canada.
But then he got a promotion
to officer of the order of Canada.
So every time I had my member pin on.
- Oh
- And he got promoted to officer
and he had his officer pin on.
We would get together.
He'd look at my pin and he'd go oh
- Cute.
- So I leapfrogged the officer category,
went right to companion.
- I love it.
Who picks, I wonder who picks.
- So
- That's awesome.
- Marty there it is right here.
- Rub it in
- Companion buddy right here.
- Is Katherine in the order?
Is she in the order?
- Katherine, Katherine O'Hara
got her order of Canada last year.
so she is now in the order.
- Is she, is she a member,
an officer, or a companion?
- Catherine is a member.
- Oh Catherine.
- But you can, you can
only join as a member
but I mean, you know, but one.
You keep working hard.
Catherine you keep plugging away.
I'm telling you.
Work a little harder.
And then you get to officer.
- Well you skipped right by that.
- Once you have.
Well I've done some amazing things.
(laughing)
- Oh my god.
- I mean I, let's face it.
- Katherine's done nothing.
- She's gotta work just a little harder.
- She's got a few things that are cool.